[Music]
I loved I loved Jesus you know I
believed in God I think my mum wanted me
to I think for a working-class woman
who's rushed off her feet and you know
the most she can hope for is that their
son don't so they don't get killed in a
in a barroom fight and Jesus I suppose
is a is an invisible free babysitter you
know if I can't see you someone's
watching you which is obviously
misplaced very sweet you know but
misplaced and I was about eight and I
was I was doing something from the Bible
and my brother came in he was older than
me his name was Bob still is and he was
about 19 and he said what you doing I
said all doing this Jesus God he said
why did you believe in God and my mum
went Bob and I knew I knew then that she
was hiding something from me and he was
he was telling the truth
I thought about it and I was a bit of a
scientist even then you know I I could
read really well by I was time I was
three I suppose I was a bit of an
experiment because I was the youngest by
11 years you know and I was into science
and nature and I suppose I was a logical
person and I thought yeah but I learned
it through body language I learned it
through that human interplay between
these two people that one was worried
about what the other one was going to
tell me so I assumed that what my
brother had something big to tell me and
my mum protecting me didn't want me to
hear it so I just made the conclusion
that he was right
now I'm just being honest you know I
mean I I can't see there could be a god
you know I mean spirituality in relating
the two different things don't forget
you know I can't make myself believe
some but I don't believe I wish there
was a God um you know and I wish he was
all the things people said he was
all-powerful and kind and and all that
but by definition that the the
impossibility is overwhelming to me
and then there's then there's religions
which use that that that truth for the
for their own personal gain and that's
something else and that's abhorrent and
disgusting religious fascism is the only
thing apart from animal cruelty that
gets my blood boiling but people believe
any God doesn't worry me at all
you know I live by I live by Christian
values I suppose you know I live by or
any religious values that preaches
forgiveness and you know do as you would
be done by and you know I just do it for
different reasons I do it because I
think this is my only time on earth and
I should I should enjoy it and be part
of it and celebrate it and be nice to
everyone because we're we're we're
animals you need to be loved and lead a
decent life so yeah if you believe in
God and that gets you through and and
you makes you a nicer person then then
then so be it but I just I just I don't
believe I and um I feel sometimes that
atheists and I am atheist not agnostic
one of the few things I'm sure of in
life I think they get a bad press that
we take the art out of beauty and the
world which is not true the fact that
you know the earth is 4.6 billion years
old and you know there are 4 million
species of animal and and they've
evolved by accident
is I think more beautiful than any
intelligent design complain
[Music]